Speaker 1: Okay. I mentioned we would talk about
this. We have an a time this week. We have time
today. And I'm not going to spend a ton of time on
it. But the CPAC straw poll, every CPAC, which is
sometimes more frequently than we might assume at
every CPAC, there's something called a straw poll.
A straw poll is a vote of those at CPAC. Who do
we want to see be the Republican nominee or vice
presidential nominee? Now, on the bonus show, we
already talked about how Carrie Lake came easily
in first place in terms of who the CPAC attendees
wanted to have as the vice presidential nominee.
The other bit of this is that in the regular
straw poll, Donald Trump easily won, very,
very easily won. And in fact, DeSantis lost by
42 points. There is an article from the Hill.
Trump easily win CPAC poll. Former President Trump
easily, easily won the straw poll. Trump won with
62%. Florida Governor Ron DeSantis, likely his
closest rival, came in at 20%, 60 to 20. That's
plus 42 for Trump. Businessman Perry Johnson, who
announced his candidacy this week, got 5%. I have
to be honest, I don't even know who that is. I
didn't even know about that. I have no clue what
the deal is with Perry Johnson. Trump won last
year's straw poll at CPAC with 59% and DeSantis
28. So last year Trump was plus 31 over to Santos,
and now Trump is plus 42. Now, a few important
things to talk about. First and foremost, do CPAC
straw polls reflect Republican primary voters? Not
really in the sense that there is a lot of people
like, listen, if you're a mitt Romney Republican
in Utah or maybe Massachusetts, where Romney
was previously governor and you kind of want
lower taxes and less business regulation, but
you're sort of like pretty reasonable when it
comes to social issues. You're not going to see
PAC at all. So your vote, you're not even part of
this entire thing. And when we look at actual
polling, what we find is that it's definitely
closer. A new Morning Consult poll that includes
a whole bunch of different candidates has Trump
plus 25 still a very big lead, but it is not 42.
There is a Emerson College poll which does have
Trump plus 41. But other than that, it's much
smaller leads, everything from Trump plus eight
all the way down to actually DeSantis even being
ahead in some polling. So is Trump winning the
Republican primary right now? Absolutely. There's
no there's no doubt. I don't think there is any.
If you look at the only way you can make the case
that Trump isn't winning is by saying we are only
going to pay attention to like the Susquehanna
Poll. And that's not a good methodology. We're
either looking at an average of polls or we're
looking at all A-rated pollsters or whatever.
But to just say based on this one poll, that's a
mediocre poll. Trump is not winning. Doesn't seem
accurate. So Trump is absolutely winning right
now. Can it change? Sure. The other aspect to
the primary, to the rather CPAC poll that
I think is very, very interesting is that
Republican candidate Vivek Ramaswamy, who is
getting very little support, he said to Stuart
Varney on Fox Business that you can just pay
to rig the CPAC straw poll. Very interesting
claim. Take a listen to this. Is this Trump's GOP?
Speaker 2: I think that the America first agenda,
the people who are behind America first, are
really committed to putting America first,
not Trump first, not vague first. It's
America first. And what I saw there,
I mean, I gave a speech. We got five standing
ovations in the middle of the speech. That's
a little funny little secret. I learned a.
Speaker 1: Stewart. Well, you're not going
to get five standing ovations at the
end. You would only get one at the end.
So it makes sense. They were in the middle.
Speaker 2: I'm new to this as an outsider.
One of the things you see as an outsider is how
corrupt this system is. There is something funny
about this. I've attended CPAC before. I don't
know. It works this way. A consultant calls
my campaign shortly after I declare and says,
Hey, we can get you up to number two on there
if you pay a few hundred thousand dollars.
Really? I was shocked, you know, And I mean,
you know what? There's a lot of people who are
making money on not only off of me, but off of
every presidential campaign. This will probably be
not only the most expensive presidential campaign,
the one that people in the industry, its
politics and industry people make so much
money off of this that one thing I'm going to be
doing throughout this campaign is exposing it.
Because you know what? I didn't get to where
I am by actually just getting exploited. And
I think the American people actually deserve
to see the sausage getting made. Did you pay?
Absolutely not. I mean, that is fake.
Speaker 1: So what if he paid? He got
ripped off. He got like zero or something.
Speaker 2: Get bumped up a little bit,
too. I said I would take my speaking. I said,
I'll take my speaking slot instead. And actually,
you can people can see that speech on my website.
The fake 2024 dot. See the speech and see the
crowd's reaction. And I think people should
be the judge of. What's really going on now.
Speaker 1: Earlier, we talked about the Kerry
Lake story. Kerry likes as someone came to her
house and said, ma'am, I'll give you a bunch of
money and a job to get out of politics. I tend not
to believe that that happened. Do I believe what
Vivek Ramaswamy is claiming actually took place,
that he was offered the opportunity
to pay to get himself the second slot?
I kind of do. I At least I'm open to it. Why?
Because there is already a sort of pay to play
scandal involving the American Conservative Union,
which is the organizer of CPAC, involving a guy
named Brian Kelsey. This guy, Matt SCHLAPP, who
runs the running back is a shady guy, to say the
least. So I am much if you say to me, David, do
you think that Carrie Lake's story is the most
likely story to be true or Vivek Ramaswamy story
is the most likely to be true? True. I think the
Ramaswamy story is much, much, much more likely
to be true. Where will the polling be in three
months? In six months? Absolutely no idea. We're
going to follow it. We're going to watch it.